there's no
circuitry no inner workings would
so everybody we've arrived at
like one of the proper oddities of
series
eight and possibly of the capaldi era
overall
in the forest of the night
yeah i have not rewatched this one since
it
aired and i know lots of other people
like hate this this was another one
that along with kill the moon a lot of
people were like why wasn't this on your
list of 10 worst episodes of doctor who
which again i don't really stand by that
video anymore
but at the time basically it was that
this thing was
too weird to annoy me i
i just it's hard for me to get mad at
something
if i can't at least figure out what it's
trying to do
sometimes i can sometimes i can't figure
out what they're trying to do
and that in and of itself will tick me
off but
that doesn't always happen sometimes i
can't figure out what the thing's trying
to do and i'm just like
maybe it's just over my head i don't
know and i can't tell you where the line
is between
when me not understanding what
somebody's trying to accomplish ticking
me off
and just making me perplexed
but for whatever reason when i watched
it the first time
in the forest of the night landed on the
perplexed side of things
re-watching it that's still mostly where
it lands i'm more
perplexed and confused by this thing
than i am
irritated or annoyed or even really all
that frustrated by it
it's just so weird
first of all the concept the very
starting premise forest
springs up out of nowhere inlet not only
in london
across the globe okay
you have my curiosity well now let's
evoke a whole crap ton
of fairy tales uh
okay like like like what well little red
riding hood will be a big one and we'll
name check hansel and gretel
and we'll have big bad wolves uh
okay except we're also going to invoke
poetry by invoking the
the poem tiger that's actually where
we're going to pull the title from and
we're going to have a tiger isn't that
neat
what does that have to do with anything
else
and and so do these fairytale illusions
have anything to do
with why the forest is no because the
forest just grew
to so that the trees consciously
will save the earth from
a solar flare that for some reason the
trees know about
um okay
and that's just kind of where it leaves
me going i got
all right it's just bizarre
this thing there are some
flat out problems with it but like i
said for the most part i'm just
befuddled as far as actual problems
there's a lot of emphasis on the kids
that um danny and clara are teaching in
this case they've taken out to
an outing that was supposed to just be
at the museum but they end up
um obviously now in this forest and
trying to
you know with the doctor trying to
figure out what's going on and
this may sound weird because i've
praised this series
for giving clara a clear job and putting
her in command of kids and have that
impacted her character
you might think i'd want to see more of
the kids except i don't
i don't care about the kids i liked what
her being around the kids and being a
teacher to these kids
did to clara as a character
i don't care about them as individuals
i just don't and none of them are
interesting
there's only one that we've seen before
and guess what she's not here that's
courtney
i don't know why she's not here she was
cited as like being a bad influence or
whatever that seems to be the group of
troublemakers why isn't she there
i don't know makes it makes it just all
the
weirder right there but though none of
the rest of them are compelling they're
fairly generic
there's the kid who's a bit of a bully
there's one who i'm
pretty sure is somewhere on the autism
spectrum but it's largely played for
laughs so i'm not sure how comfortable i
am with that and then there's
maeve who's okay
um so she hears voices
all right low-level psychic you know the
show's done that before
you know as an inherent trait okay
all right except the voices she hears
are the
trees all right and she can hear them
because her older sister's
missing wait what
and it's oh boy it doesn't help that
that actress is so far out of her depth
i don't want to go too hard i don't want
to be like she's terrible
i feel i feel bad for her the same
reason i felt bad for the actors who
played
chloe i can speak chloe weber
in fear her because here as there i feel
like
she just didn't know what to do with
this direction and as a result it comes
off as
really stiff and awkward here's the
thing with young actors really anyone
under the age of say
12 or 13 is that you
are going to have a very hard time
getting a performance out of them that
cannot be rooted in something that they
have personally experienced
and that is somewhere rooted in their
reality the best child actors are kids
who
usually have a pretty strong resemblance
to the characters that they are
portraying
the problem with shows like doctor who
is
you need actors who can respond to very
outlandish things that they don't have
any real basis
in reality for and while kids may have
great imaginations it doesn't mean they
know how to
act as if those things are real in the
way that an
actor needs to do so in the case of this
poor girl in case of maeve
you know she's she's just standing there
going
and like i get it i get the motion is
like she's seeing something that she's
trying to fend away but like you can
tell
this young actress is struggling so hard
just
like she doesn't know how to act this
and it's
so clear and again i'm not sure i would
have expected a kid that age to
know how to how to realistically act
what was being asked of her
but that that is a problem with the show
so here's another thing and again this
is kind of weird for me
because i had a similar issue with
time of the doctor normally broadly
speaking
i like a fairy tale vibe to stories but
i
didn't like the fairy tale vibe to time
of the doctor now
for that one i cited as being an ill fit
for
a regeneration story and that may still
have been it
but here again we have a doctor who
story that has a fairy tale kind of vibe
to it
but really doesn't work and i'm just
starting to wonder if this is just a bad
fit for that kind of vibe
i don't know i think
well if you don't roll with the fairy
tale style
vibe of this thing the logistics make
no sense whatsoever
okay so the trees all grow immediately
to protect the planet because
trees can just do that on a whim
collectively
uh okay i don't know if i
i don't know if they were trying to bank
off of some of the concepts dropped
in um the doctor the widow and the
wardrobe
but you know that was a while back at
this point and
they know that the response to the
doctor the winner of the wardrobe wasn't
great
so that's like the only precedent that
exists for what they're doing
and it wasn't particularly well received
so that's that's weird and then
after this after this solar flare hits
and burns off the the protective
oxygen airbag bubble
the trees just vanish
in sparkly fairy dust
and then and then the and this this is
the one part that makes me go
wait what even at the time i saw it
it was that that girl's older sister
just appears in like the sparkle dust
like the trees brought her back
that is completely abandoning even the
slightest
hint of doing anything other than pure
fantasy i don't necessarily have a
problem with the doctor
having fantasy elements except that at
the end of the day it is a science
fantasy show
it does have some basis in the in
in all of that so this is the kind of
story that
i mean granted the way they told it it
wouldn't have worked but like the
logistics of the trees
and everything else i could have bought
it might have even thought it was a neat
idea
if it wasn't earth if it was
some other planet some alien planet or
heck even some
alternate dimension version of earth
just not our earth
because this doesn't track like
any of it it's so ridiculous but i don't
even feel like it's worth getting into
the logistics because you can tell from
the vibe of this thing
it's not trying to be logistically
bulletproof
it's going for a feel and a tone that i
don't think it really achieves
i can i can tell well i can't tell what
the overall goal of this episode was
i can tell what vibe it's going for but
i don't know
why it's going for it i don't know what
that's in service of and what it feels
like is going for the fairy tale vibe
was an
excuse to not have to
pass a basic logic test on any of the
things that actually go on in the
episode
that's what it ends up feeling like
whether or not that's actually the case
i don't know this is just such
a weird episode it's the kind of story
that
you know what might have worked in a
medium that
has a larger initial
um willful suspension of disbelief this
might have worked as a
issue of a comic book or you know really
go back and have it have been like the
comic strips in the old doctor who
magazine this would have been fine
for that you know like have have
this happen with frobisher that would
have worked that's
fine you know have the shape-shifting
penguin have the instant force
cool but there are certain things that
don't
work with how the show especially modern
era doctor who
has established what it is in
television form especially 8 series in
it's just so weird this thing
and i can't bring myself to hate it
because i'm just
too i'm too confused to be worked up
so that's in the force of the night have
you rewatched it lately what'd you think
about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do
and i do believe you know what it is
like share subscribe i have a patreon
it helps keep the lights on and i keep
this whole thing
up and running and me you know actually
paying my bills
uh plus usual stuff links for various
social media and whatnot
and merch etc down in the description
check them out
or don't end of the day you're the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
bye